The moment you hear the word
fundamentalist, you start thinking of a
Muslim. Ah, he's a Muslim. Ah, he's a
fundamentalist. He's an extremist.
And we Muslim go on the difference. No,
no, no. I'm not a fundamentalist. I'm
not an extremist. I tell the world, yes,
Dr. ZAK KNIGHT IS AN EXTREMIST. I'm
extremely kind. I'm extremely loving.
I'm extremely merciful. I'm extremely
honest. I'm extremely just.
Can anyone tell me what is wrong in
being extremely loving, extremely
merciful, extremely kind, extremely
honest, extremely just?
The Quran says in surah bakra chapter
number two verse number 208,
enter into Islam wholeheartedly, not
partly. You have to follow Islam
extremely.
You have to be EXTREMELY HONEST. YOU
CAN'T SAY when it benefits me, if it
benefits you, be honest. If it doesn't
benefit you, don't be honest. You have
to be extremely honest always. You have
TO BE EXTREMELY JUST ALWAYS IRRESPECT IF
IT'S AGAINST you or for you. Allah says
in the Quran in chapter 4 verse number
135,
oh you believe stand out for stand out
as witness to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
for justice even if it be against
yourself against your parents against
your relatives against rich or poor
Allah protects all saying that you have
to be extremely just you can't say when
it benefits me I'm just when it doesn't
benefit me and my parents I'm not just
so in Islam you have to follow the
teachings of Islam extremely
so therefore I say I'm an extremist
but I'm extremist in the correct
direction you can be extremist in the
right direction you can be extremist in
the wrong direction so Muslim is
supposed to be an extremist in the
correct direction extremely honest
extremely kind extremely merciful
extremely just extremely loving.
We should not be extremist in the wrong
direction in the wrong things.
The third most common misconceptions
regarding Islam among the non-Muslims is
that Muslims are terrorist
and especially after 9/11 the 11th of
September 2001 attack on the twin tower
and after 77 the London bombing.
It was a common statement
THAT ALL MUSLIMS ARE NOT TERRORIST but
all terrorists are Muslims
indicating that every terrorist you form
is a Muslim. All Muslims won't be
terrorist but every terrorist is a
Muslim and I gave a talk in response to
this in 2006.
Is terrorism a Muslim monopoly? And that
give more detail because this is only
answering one aspect. But in detail you
can refer to my talk on is terrorism
Muslim monopoly on terrorism.
And I also given the talk if you want
more information about jihad and
terrorism. I have given the talk on
jihad and terrorism and Islamic
perspective. If you hear both these
talks you will realize the statistics
and the truth and we'll be able to
answer the non-Muslims in a better way.
What is the meaning of the word
terrorist?
A terrorist by definition means a person
who causes terror. Simple.
If a criminal
looks or sees a policeman, he's
terrified. So in English language, the
policeman is the terrorist
for the criminal.
And I got this when I was in Bombay.
In times of India, it came on the front
page
that Inspector Wan,
he terrorizes the criminals of Mumbai.
I got this terrorist from there.
So
in this context, I tell every Muslim
should be a terrorist. In this context,
every Muslim should be a terrorist to
the antisocial element. Every Muslim
should be a terrorist for the rapist, to
the thief, to the robber.
But I'm aware
that terrorist normally means generally
to terrorize the innocent human being.
IN THIS CONTEXT, NO MUSLIM SHOULD EVER
be a terrorist. We Muslims should only
terrorize the antisocial element, the
rapist, the robber, those who create
facad. AND THE QURAN SAYS THAT in
suryanfal chapter number 8 verse number
60 prepare your steed of HORSE AND
TERRORIZE THE HEARTS OF the antisocial
element.
So when I became popular in UK
and when the Labor Party lost and the
Conservative came to power in 2010,